du weißt es gilt international ein
Folterverbot für uns wurde eine Ausnahme
gemacht wir dürfen das Fragenlotto
spielen und du darfst die harmlose und
die furchtlose ziehen die roten Falten
eigentlich unter das Folterverbot aber
kannst auch blind ziehen ja ma ich
glaube ich ist am besten ist am besten
ja wir gehen in die Vollen ist doch
schön ja bitte mach auf mach sie auf
okay die ach so die
Frage okay
soll ich die Frage Vorlesen ja bitte in
die Kamera hast du überhaupt Ahnung von
dem was du erzählst dein Tutorial zum
Thema Schweinegrippe ist ja doch etwas
umstritten ich würde mal sagen zu jeder
Mensch macht irgendwie Fehler und
vielleicht habe ich mich auch ein
bisschen falsch informiert und nicht
vielleicht so detailliert informiert wie
ich es eigentlich hätte machen sollen
bei so einem Thema es ist jetzt wirklich
in den Medien so diskutiert worden wie
nur möglich und ich hätte mich
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr fixieren
sollen wie der Krankheitsverlauf ist und
vielleicht auch was die Wirkung von
Antibiotica bewirkt und ja diese Fehler
sind mir schon aufgefallen und ich hätte
es auch besser machen können habe ich
mir gesagt aber wie gesagt nobody ist
perfect und du arbeitest dran ganz genau
gut das heißt ist es für dich Prinzip
dass du nicht perfekt bist oder ist das
auch des dieses bürgerjournalismuses der
durch die Gurus ja quasi eingeführt
worden ist dass man quasi immer noch mal
hinen muss ich weiß nicht genau ob der
wirklich recht hat ich informiere mich
noch an anderen Quellen klar ich
versuche die Information jetzt schon
wirklich so genau wie möglich zu machen
und so auch rüberzubringen aber manchmal
passieren natürlich Fehler und jedem
passieren Fehler und das kann man dann
auch nicht mehr nachtränglich vermeiden
man kann vielleicht eine Bemerkung
schreiben da und da das stimmt dann und
aber ich versuche wie gesagt mein
Zuschauern Detail getetreue und wahre ja
Videos zu willst du das denn in Zukunft
dann lassen solche Videos zu machen über
solche Themen oder willst du dich
professionalisieren also in gerade bei
solchen Themen würde ich mich wie du
schon gerade gesagt hast
professionalisieren und ja genauer und
präziser werden okay willst du dann mal
ich sag mal gibt ja Weiterbildung für
Journalisten sowas machen oder hast du
PL natürlich eine Überlegung wert aber
habe ich jetzt noch nicht wirklich
überlegt gut okay nicht mal eine
grüne so ja man muss schon den
gesalzenen Finger in die Wunde
legen war der Erfolg deines Kanals
planbar ich würde mal sagen ich habe
ohne viel Erwartung ein Video
hochgeladen und wäre es schlecht
angekommen hätte ich vielleicht nicht
weiter gemacht aber da so rasant
aufwärts ging muss ich natürlich
weitermachen und klar das ist jetzt
keine Pflicht von mir aber mir hat dann
Spaß gemacht und das ist jetzt zu einem
meiner größten hobbiys geworden gab's
denn Leute in deinem freundeskist die
gesagt haben hey mach doch das ist was
für dich da kommst du sicher gut an ich
hat schon einige Freunde die gemeint
haben du wärst ein super Beauty Experte
und ja wie man sieht bin ich jetzt her
Tutorial der super Beauty Experte kann
man sagen meine
rote oh Gott deine Mimik ist ja nicht
sehr abwechslungsreich kannst du auch
etwas anderes als Grinsen klar kann ich
auch Ernst sein und und ich bin auch
manchmal ernst aber ich meine the show
must go on und man sollte
auch ich will einfach diese positive
Energie in meinen Videos ausstrahlen und
da sollte man nicht unbedingt krimmig
reinschauen GST du in deinem
Freundeskreis als die positive Energie
ja die positive Energiekugel und die
Garantie für positive Energie werde ich
dasin genannt ja und ist das nicht
manchmal ein bisschen belastend auch
wenn man fühlt man sich da so eine Rolle
gedrängt und sagt ich will nicht wi auch
mal also wenn ich wütend bin dann bin
ich auch wütend wenn ich ernst bin dann
bin ich ernst also ja ich fühle mich
dann nirgends
reingedrät weiter geht's muss ich sie
alle beantworten auch am liebsten sind
mir immer alle
okay nächste Frage woher hast du deine
sympathische Ausstrahlung ja die habe
ich natürlich meiner Mutter und meinem
Vater zu verdanken sind beides lebensfoh
und das hat sich garantiert auf mich
übertragen und aus dem Grund bin ich
auch so sympathisch und habe so ein
sympathisches ausstrahlen auftreten gibt
bei euch kein Streit zu Hause ja klar
das ist ganz normal es gehört natürlich
zum Leben eines jeden Menschen dazu aber
muss herrsch ein sehr sehr gutes Klima
zu Hause weitermachen
weiter
okay nächste
Frage wie viele Kilo Gel hast du
eigentlich in deinen Haaren muss man
heute sagen etwas abgespeckt ja heute
habe ich wirklich abgespckt heute habe
ich kein Gel die Zuschauer mögen das
auch so ganz natürlich mit meinen Haaren
und ich würde mal sagen eine Tube Gel
hält da wirklich ein Monat also auch
wenn es nach viel aussieht hinter der
Kamera bin ich überwiegend so und als
her Tutorial muss man natürlich auch das
ist sozusagen auch mein Markenzeichen
geworden und da sieht man mich das
öfteren dann auch mit diesen Haaren mit
den vielen Gelen mein du weißt was in
ein Z Jahren Karneval passiert wird das
als Helm verkauft das W eine gute Idee
so
einorollest du
vertreiben ich wä du toll
okay die Fragen sind echt
super nächste Frage ist was macht dich
so unwiderstehlich ich würde mal einfach
sagen ich bin so natürlich wie ich bin
wie ich auch nor Leben bin und
vielleicht macht das mich so
unwiderstehlich dass ich einfach normal
bin und nicht versuche perfekt zu sein
das würde ich mal sagen ja und
vielleicht weil ich auch viel
lache okay nächste
Frage ich gespannt was ihr mir so für
Fragen
geben was du da machst kann das nicht
jeder ich würde mal
sagen klar ist jeder aber nicht jeder
kann es so gut verkaufen wie ich und
nicht jeder kann es so gut rüberbringen
wie ich also da bin ich selbstbewusst
genug zu sagen dass ich anders bin als
andere und es gibt viele die es auch
versuchen nachzumachen aber dann nicht
so ein Erfolg haben also man muss
wirklich sich von der Masse abheben und
so seinen Charakter wiederspiegeln und
ich glaube es liegt auch zum Großteil an
meinem Auftreten dass ich so viel Erfolg
hab und wie ich das dann auch
rüberbringe aber ist es nicht so du
sagst man zeigt sich muss man nicht zu
viel von sich preis geben ja okay
natürlich muss man immer aufpassen was
man von sich preis gibt ich als ich
jetzt auf Youtube angefangen habe hätte
ich jetzt nie erwartet über die 1000
Abonnenten zu kommen hätte ich das z.B
gewusst hätte ich z.B mein Nachnamen nie
veröffentlicht aber sowas kann man
natürlich nie einplanen also der
Nachname ist schon Haken könnte man so
sagen aber mehr hast du auch nicht
verraten n auch nicht wo ich jetzt genau
wohne oder also Stutgart ist groß genug
ja ja ich meine auch es ist eben enger
Kontakt zu den Leuten und es ist beim
Schauspieler der öffnet sich auch man
öffnet sich ja zu in
Teilen okay nächste Frage das Studio für
deine Tutorials sehen ja ziemlich arm
aus wann kannst du dich endlich mal an
einen schönen hin wann kannst du dir
endlich mal einen schönen Hintergrund
leisten eine Fototapete müsste doch drin
sein
das ist würde ich mal
sagen das zeigt einfach diesen Jungen
der in seinem ganz einfachen Zimmer
seine Videos machen das ist das was ich
ja immer sage Natürlichkeit ist die
beste Methode sympathisch auf die
Menschen zu wirken und auch so viele wie
möglich zu erreichen weil ich meine
meine Zuschauer sind genauso normale
Menschen wie ich und wieso sollte man
jetzt großartig eine Fototapete nehmen
und ich weiß nicht also ich fühle mich
in Zimmer wohl und meine Zuschauer
angeblich auch also glaub schon also
Studio käme für dich nicht in Frage
nicht wirklich also ich würde mir da zu
professionell vorkommen das ist ja
gerade das ich zeig einfach den
natürlichen Jungen der vor der Kamera
steht in seinem ganz normal im Zimmer
sitzt und Videos macht was sind die
Erfolgsfaktoren D man dass man sich
einfach von der natürlichen Seite zeigt
und nicht jetzt großartig rummacht ein
Hintergrund aufbut damit es wiröglich
schön aussieht ich zeig einfach so wie
ich bin und so wie ich auch in meinem
Zimmer lebe letzte Frage letzte Frage
die Daumenschrauben werden
angelegt oh Gott musst du dein Haar
nicht oft mit Babypuder pudern weiß
kennst du den Hintergrund dieser Frage
ja damals in Mittelalter haben sich ja
die nein nein nein das ist ein Tipp von
dem schnellsten derock wenn dann so viel
Kram im Haar hat okay damit es nicht zu
schnell fettet oder so nein muss ich
eigentlich nicht ja wenn man sich
täglich die Haare wäscht und die guten
Produkte nutzt denke ich jetzt nicht
dass ich jetzt meine Haare mit Babypuder
pudern muss gut aber du musst ja
verschiedene Produkte testen das heißt
du testest ja auch wel e kein Muss es
ist eher so etwas freiwilliges also klar
bekomme ich ständig Angebote von
verschiedenen Firmen willst du nicht
unsere Produkte austesten und ich
behalte mir einfach immer das Recht vor
die Produkte nicht zu reviewen und wenn
Sie jetzt vielleicht nicht gut sind wenn
ich merke okay die sind jetzt nicht
wirklich gut als wärden Sie ein Video
wert und so ein recht behalte ich mir
immer vor und dann
weiß ich genau was ich vorstellen was
nicht aber es kann ja mal sein dass du
benutzt was und es bleiben Reste im Haar
kleben oder sonst was hast du nicht
solche unglücklichen Erfahrung schon
gemacht nein bis jetzt noch nicht nee
also so schlecht war noch nichts nein
dann vielen Dank bitte schön hat mich
sehr gefreut mich
ebenfalls
danke